I get a feeling there's gonna be a riot
I don't be the news because all right it
is time for another wonderful episode of
safe space how is everybody thank you
for tuning in we're very excited to be
here back in the studio with my homeboy
Aaron how are you Aaron good Garin I
know you look more to this sir every
every week of just hearing me scream and
shout I'm sure you're excited about it
big news guys big news I'm now starting
a once-a-month podcast I famo call a tin
foil hat and it's a conspiracy theory
podcast totally dedicated to discussing
conspiracy theories with friends who are
into conspiracy theories and proud to
announce the first episode will be next
week and my guess is no other than Eddie
Bravo you know I'm from just a jujitsu
superstar the first guy to tap a gracie
like a grown-ass man yeah he's going to
be in there we're gonna talk everything
we're gonna go deep dog hope you guys
tune I'm super excited I have a bunch
people I want to talk to I might do that
in a regular to I ain't afraid I'll get
it going I'm excited about this I love
conspiracy don't even get me started on
pizza gate we'll get into that later
we're getting that later we will discuss
that trust me on that ah what date so I
got I don't got a lot of dates man I'm
be honestly now that we stopped doing
the naughty show I'd plan on doing that
for a couple months straight next year
and guess what since we decided not to
do it anymore daddy's gotta fill his
calendar so that is that
I am gonna start doing privates you know
I've flown in the Minnesota I've flown
into vegas flown a new I'll come do your
party your rose you're you're our
Christmas events your hanukkah's would
I'll do all what was the what's uh
what's the Black Christmas what's that
that's a condom I don't know [ __ ]
Kwanzaa show dark I'll show up and get
microns on I don't even know what that's
about but I'll do it I'll wear a dashiki
I'll get a dashiki on one of those weird
kind of hats I'll do some weird dancing
like the old black guy from the that
band that's and Tennessee Tennessee
remember that band I what were they
called something's gonna hit me up but
and then they just paid that one guy he
just dance like he just did the weird
dance he's oh my god oh he don't say ha
lavelle kid here today on and on they
did it oh and this is all he did he just
dance oh by the way thinking about
banging out quick a quick Christmas
album ok I'm thing about recorded
Christmas album called Tripoli [ __ ] up
the classics and I just sing all your
favorite Christmas tunes poorly for the
holidays this is christmas merry
Christmas to you I just gotta find some
knock operated stuff and bang that out
homeboy nobody's with me on that one I'm
still trying to get that bands name oh
my god I here to hold get an a day
filleted huh Oh arrested devel arrested
development that's what should have been
yes the old the old the old the old
black guy to dance on stage got paid
bucks just as a whole go to hear the
hill and he just danced and you that
band was gonna make it cuz there was
like literally 30 people on the stage
there's no way you're making that much
money the lead singer got the page a bit
like god damn we just we did a whole
show for a ham sandwich that's what it
is
so that's where we're super excited back
in LA was in Chicago shout out chitown
shout-out to everybody at the comedy bar
Manny in the whole group wonderful staff
wonderful Club this is a gorgeous club
man the comedy boy bar is a gorgeous
club it was a lot of fun we had packed
shows three out of four nights I excuse
me throughout the four shows were packed
and it was great I had a great time so
basically I want to take my story of
getting to chicago i fly into chicago
now Dana books all my flights she's very
nice she's kind enough to do that for me
because she knows I'm a little slow and
I book it bad so she booked for me but
she always gets me on the earliest
flight in and the earliest flight out I
have a friend of mine who is a stand-up
comic out there who told me I could
crash at his place why they're doing it
why I'm out there just let me crash you
know usually when you do the road you
get a room with your gig this one
doesn't come with that whatever fine I
wanted to play chicago I'm cool that
I'll I'll just find somewhere to crash
so I talked to my friend he's like yeah
man you could crash in my place no
problem and i felt like i was intruding
but I kept asking as it got closer if it
was okay and they were like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I like okay
that's cool I've asked you five ten
times you say I can I should be able to
crash your place right I mean I'm Aaron
if you're like hair and I'm saying i'd
say i'm coming in LA hey man I crash
your place first let me say yeah yeah
okay and then I'm like are you sure you
really want me to if not let me know
what do you say right there
okay okay okay right totally didn't do
that at all I would totally be cool if
they said not to be like dude and she
goes where I got this prey he goes well
I got this place and there's no
furniture go okay that's fine if you
don't want me to crash it I totally
understand you tell me no it's fine
crash crash okay so I fly in to chicago
i fly into o'hare i don't know if you
guys knows but I have a UH one year old
phone that functions like it's from the
1800s it's brand new old ever I get the
brand-new old phone we're like you as
soon as you get the phone the new phone
comes out it's so light years better
than your old phone but the [ __ ]
verizon wireless didn't tell you the new
ones coming out tomorrow because they
need to make sales so they want you to
buy the old one instead of saying hey do
come back tomorrow I'm still here by the
phones coming out tomorrow you ever had
that no that's why i don't go to verizon
where do you go AT&T oh you do that how
is eighteen t it's not bad I'm thinking
about getting off the iphone ooh I'll
tell you why because I think their
sinister I think I go back to the tin
foil hat I think that you ever know so a
new phone comes out they send you
another operating system the like new
operating system download now that
system is Yakuza I mean excuse me
seppuku it is your phone it's a program
to tell your phone to commit honorable
suicide it's like start breaking down
now and then you knows nothing works
right you can't you know your battery
just goes to [ __ ] your battery just goes
to [ __ ] this but i cannot i cannot what
is going on here you know he's not
downloaded update yeah but then you're
like I miss it on the good [ __ ] are you
and by the way can we talk about the
fact that the iphones new gmail is
horrible like you don't know it's like
it's literally like it's i can assure
film is your painting you don't know
where we are going whether you're like
okay here's this email this is
yesterday's and here's the email that's
gonna come tomorrow and you don't know
which one's the last one it's a little
walk it it's can feel eat like stop
reinventing the wheel yeah we the email
thing was cool we don't need that okay
you don't need to update that how about
give me a [ __ ] battery that doesn't
die how about that one you know cuz not
reinventing the wheel how about how
about just give me me a video that runs
properly anyways so I get as soon as I
land even you keep this battery cement
used me if you turn your phone off you
could save your battery yeah now it's
still draining even airplane mode should
save your battery yeah nope wow this
thing got the mission and it wants to go
it wants to go kamikaze and call it a
day in the name of its its its its
people it's ridiculous so the phone so
here I am my phones dying I gotta charge
you Chicago O'Hare Airport has no plugs
to charge they've just no one got in the
iphone in Chicago yeah yeah I baby yeah
so anyways so I'm my phones dying I tell
my friend hey I just landed cuz they go
i'll pick you up at the airport I just
lena i gave me i get a text on them cool
I'm like what cool yeah cool yeah not
cool on my way yeah good meeting are you
coming hello are you coming are you
there is everything okay and I have this
series of texts to this person that they
don't worry and then all of a sudden
they get it I get a flip with with their
address so I'm like oh so now you're not
coming yeah so I don't like this address
was this week as Chicago is like huge
yeah and there's all these different
kind of places like little area you
don't know where you are in good that's
the okay I'll get into a but nobody I
don't know where it's going so I gotta
go I gotta get out of this Airport
somehow so I'm like I'm just I don't
know place a I'm gonna air B&B it you
ever air B&B it I haven't yet no okay
era P&B for you don't know what it is
and that's probably not a lot a lot of
you it's basically what they call it the
uber of hotels basically you crash it
someone's house and for a night and they
give you like it's cheap it's really
like 450 bucks you can chill at
somebody's house with a like Grandma
stroking out in the corner it can be
cheap it can't be true always do well a
lot I mean like I found place on there
two hundred dollars for an entire house
yeah the night suppose that is cheap
yeah that's kind of cheap yeah but then
there were some ten dollar ones Oh ten
dollars and Bambi I'm like why is it
homelessness when there's ten dollar air
B&B that's a worn crackhead [ __ ] ten
dollars yeah is that that much no no
certainly not you can Panhandle ten
dollars in two hours you just have to be
homeless with a phone that's charged
I've seen holes filled with iPads dog I
mean do don't hold us are a little
different than the rest of the world's
helm us yeah they're just more like
people live outdoors they're little
different nobody you know with me on
that one frontiersman okay yeah that's
really what they are and they have they
have a talent name is Gil they usually
do usually yeah crazy I found a
ten-dollar air B&B what size was the
sleeping bag always was a picture of
like a roll of toilet paper on a bed
that's all of us and then you so
realizing oh [ __ ] this Airbnb is in
charge oh I'm sure it's inch i rack man
like you guys are no chiraq is that's
based on the spike lee movie about
hollers this area of chicago whoever
plays shooting each other and that's
though and that's where you're crying
baby you could say there for ten dollars
inch i rack like that's crazy it's like
cheap affordable and you look at people
like I had a great time crushers a
you're crazy dude that's prior they just
wrote it yes I stay totally did they
made up a fake [ __ ] account and they
just like really just dude that's like
if that ain't in a place is gonna get
shot up that it's a crack house or yours
get some serial killers dungeon yeah
that's a ten dollar serial killer
discount he's gonna turn you into a
walrus it's like 10 bucks huh do you
want after it's like when you see like
fast food gets so cheap like dollar Big
Mac is like do you really want your food
to be a dollar sometimes really you want
a dollar hamburger if that's all you got
that's well yeah you got ten dollars got
crashed somewhere and the only place let
you crash is chiraq you're gonna stay
there but we're assuming we're normal
human being for a little scratch in our
pocket you have are you don't buy a five
dollar pizza the hot and ready [ __ ] yeah
but still that's not even good yeah i
know you are you want to spend at least
ten dollars on a whole pie like at least
i got a dollar I got five minutes I'll
take that your little here yeah we're
dollars I got a dollar I'm outdoorsman
cuz I live outdoors I'll take your
dollar whopper if I got options yeah I
don't want to take that that dollar
hamburger I don't want to live in China
act for ten bucks a night in some weird
dude sex dungeon for ten dollars he gets
a probe yeah right like ten dollars
that's crazy yeah there's something
that's some wrong with that um I would
not go for it yeah so so nobody came and
pick me up nobody was saying tebow just
wouldn't answer my phone oh yeah if
you're ever down now just Oh tebow won't
answer his phone oh it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] he wasn't at redzone then he
wasn't at the red zone and I thought I
was doing something else he ended up not
doing that and I'm just like what the
[ __ ] man my phone just can't stay
charged it's ridiculous anyways so I go
to school I just take the I just I go I
go dude we gotta man up right here we
got to figure this [ __ ] out you don't
want to let you all be Tom Hanks living
in a [ __ ] Airport in [ __ ] Chicago
for the rest of your life so it's like I
had to charge my my phone and I had the
fit I couldn't get anyone to tell me
what [ __ ] train to take in the
Chicago blue line found out
blue lines guy told me kept telling me
where to get off I couldn't remember
because I did drugs for a while and my
memory is shot buddy told me get off on
something in Lane and I just remember
that and I took in and it was kind of
cool because when I fly into place as a
headline in comic i usually get picked
up the airport taking ray to my my hotel
I perform and I get back out and I never
get to see the city so this is kind of
cool to take it in and walk around and
take in Chicago Chicago's a real ass
city huh it's a real just a gorgeous
City and this club is gorgeous like the
comedy bar is owned by sahara and a
couple of our owners I didn't mean staff
is great gorgeous club nice yeah and
it's fun you know but here's my
president downtown downtown nice yeah I
pay for an air B&B in the south side
which is chiraq I know I'm from the
north side from Chicago yeah so south
sides bad side right hell yeah that's
well the [ __ ] goes down yeah now d I was
talking people there and they grieve me
but do you think they just pulled a
[ __ ] ah what was the corner what was
it called know what was that TV show the
ire the wire they where they just pushed
all the [ __ ] crazy people in the one
little area and said have fun we're not
gonna [ __ ] with you probably and that's
why all the shootings have happened
mm-hmm it's crazy so I do these shows
this weekend the clubs are great and
it's a new club so you always want to
kind of be like gotta keep it chill
gotta make a good first impression so
they bring you back in ninety nine
percent of time they bring me back every
show I did there was a white chick
complaining to somebody about my act
crying about my act because they want
political correctness and I refuse to do
that and it's just ridiculous every show
so like you know there is no more
symbolic thing of white privilege than
political correctness
just think about it white women in
particular it's white women and beta
males guys watch too much romantic
comedy [ __ ] that go to Ghana clubs
thinking that their view of the world is
how everybody else should at cortland
there what's more white privilege than
that yep the thought they we have to
play by your rules and what you think
and I talked to first it was an open mic
her chick who I talked to before the
show very cordial I did my act I gough
stays they started the open mic after
and this chick just without saying it
laid into me she goes I went through the
same thing you guys went through I get
it you're a little weirded out right now
cuz I went through it too and I'm like
is this [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about me and
she totally was the staff was like oh
we're sorry oh so there's an open mic
after the show yes which is fine that's
traumatic enough well I mean if you flip
the other way than by the time oh yeah
headliner gets up their nose certainly
but I just if I was in the audience I'd
be like all right I'm out of here well
they month the bartender said that's the
longest people have ever stayed was
after my Shelley clearly enjoyed it ah I
mean I didn't walk anybody dog I mean
and I try to walk people yeah if I walk
two tables I do my job they're like we
have one guy Harry walked like four
people I'm like gonna look like you're
gonna be a new record this weekend yeah
I got a well she's not reading the room
right yeah well God's big white
privilege now she thinks cause of her
views in the world so the second night
there's this guy he looks like he
conducts a symphony and he's with this
girl and they're sipping wine and they
look like oh when do you think of Heidi
tour to think of all all the white
douchebags in aa trading places with
Eddie Murphy you remember that like all
the younger hi guys named Chet and this
is this is Mindy like that's the by day
ad and the other half is a bunch of
foreigners because there's a lot of uh
there is a lot of tourists ago this club
so there's some foreigners a lot of
people from out of town and there are
the great type these two miserable
miserable
this chick looks like she's watching me
choke out her puppy like I'm just
grabbing a puppy and choking it out rain
from her so soon as i get done they call
the mandarin and they're just [ __ ]
laying into her i felt bad like I don't
want anybody well it's a weirdo what
southern managers fault no but but what
they're trying to do is get me fired or
have me never worked there again yeah
which is what they're trying to do which
is you don't see it anywhere else the
only thing that's close to that is being
a chef in a restaurant yeah that's
literally stand-up is like being a chef
in the restaurant people always want to
talk to the manager about the food and
want to talk to the chef and then they
try to get the people fired it's how
might you just don't like it and you
order another dish care you just don't
come back the place will be fun without
you yeah but the comedy clubs can be
weird not this one in particular but
kinda coach me we're like one person
complains act like it's a billion
complaints they've gotten yeah like it's
just a billion [ __ ] everybody's upset
if you like the thing when I'm gonna get
Amy Schumer later but Amy Schumer she's
paying a 10,000 seat theater 200 people
up that's not a lot of people nope in
10,000 people that's not even a teardrop
nope a raindrop anything in a bucket of
water that isn't even a tiniest bit of
water it's gonna happen you're not gonna
get everybody to agree on everything so
this girl comes up to me I I see her
she's leaving I think she's afraid to
come my way so go come here come here
good there are the people complaining
the people complaining okay because even
though I enjoy people walking out two of
two or three I still wish people would
have a great time whether that's
hypocrisy which I just think it's just
this weird thing I have well it's fine
you want walk go go but ultimately I
would love you for you to have a good
time so they come oh I start talking to
him and she's just like you don't
understand like I mean I've had people
come up to me going you're set makes me
so sad and I'm like I don't care and I
took she starts lecture me on comedy and
I go listen lady this conversation isn't
me trying to get notes for me on my act
I'm never going to change my act just
you're never gonna change your opinion
well the truth is she will over life
when she lives some life and she's
realized not to take everything so
[ __ ] serious so when the next time
she comes back to that Club and is also
offend ya by someone completely
different yeah yeah and the guy the beta
guy just sitting there and all he wants
to do is bang this chick but he's he's
watched so many romantic comedies he has
no clue how to talk to women or handle
his [ __ ] [ __ ] but this girl goes why
don't you learn you should learn the
punch up not punch down and that is the
[ __ ] problem that's the problem with
political correctness is that so
subjective and it's basically she's
determining whether I'm punching up or
I'm punching down I go what jokes they
punch down on Oh doing coke out of girls
asses I'm like how's that punching down
guys do it all the time and girls like
guys do it all the [ __ ] time who's
the punching down on that I'll talking
about teachers [ __ ] their kids that's
happening and my question was what is
the correlation between teachers boning
their students and schools getting shoot
up by kids there's I bet you the more
teachers have bone their students the
last kids shoot up schools I'm not
saying it's a scientific no I'm just
saying after I bust a nut I don't want
to fight anybody true that's all I'm
trying to say so there's this there's
this hierarchy there's this there's this
weird system of political correctness
and which mostly is driven by white
women in particular white women oh it's
either really young women are really old
white women over 40 are the number one
age demographic for getting offended
like I talk about on stage they practice
talking to managers in the office in the
mirror in their kitchen before they go
to the shell they practice I'd like to
talk to the manager real quick I didn't
find out I was exciting at all you know
they just love to get a fast they get
offended on other people's behalfs
people aren't even there to get all
things that sound like they might be
offensive like the coke of a girl's butt
hole that sounds in some weird way might
be offensive it's not there is an
interaction between
men and women and depending on what
perspective you're coming from you could
like if I hear women talk about guys
being dumb I'm offended by that I
constantly fight with Dana about the
fact that commercials are constantly
about guys being dumb [ __ ] she doesn't
see it now this girl saw me doing coke
of some ladies [ __ ] as me being
degraded to her she getting free coke
man yep you're getting free blow let me
do it all your ass yeah sonic you look
great in the story either yeah I'm do
coke out some girls [ __ ] poop shoot
why do I like that who knows people need
to start treating comi like movies where
if you don't like the move you just saw
oh whoops move on yeah you're out 18
bucks it's your fine then because the
notion has and you see it and it's like
dude daytime television is so bad right
now because daytime television is geared
mostly towards women housewife's and
it's just all programming it's just
programming programming programming them
that everything is offensive everybody's
degrading to them the whole view is a
[ __ ] fast ESPN has just become ethnic
ppl bitching and moaning about life they
have this one Hispanic show the woman
out there is so beyond annoying like
everything she does is like a [ __ ]
affront to a her Latino heritage
everything it's like I just wanna find
out who won who lost why they won why
they lost that's all I wanna know I
don't want your butt am i hop you know
and she does he has to get soup odds
just annoying it's just annoying I can't
watch anymore and he is then wonders why
nobody watches their channel because the
whole [ __ ] morning is social justice
warriors so I decided that there are
rules to political correctness and I'm
up break down the rules according to
white women on what can be said by what
type of comic I've wrote about this long
time ago on myspace and I'm not going to
get into it right now rules are
political regulars according to White
guilty crowds in particular white women
everyone can react Asians and middle
Easterns that's a rule you can rack them
all you want my theory is the reason you
pick on them is because they bombed
America if you drop a bomb or you fly a
plane in
to a building in America you are free
the most liberal [ __ ] in the
world will [ __ ] on a terrorist or Asian
driver it's just the rule Pearl Harbor
911 we can light you up those are the
rules no one's ever going to cry Asians
try to make it a big deal that they get
picked on but you shouldn't have [ __ ]
attacked us okay asian comics pretty
much do racist jokes about Asians that's
our whole act about how Asian they are
okay this makes white women it
comfortable remember these are all what
makes white women comfortable they make
jokes about are racist jokes about being
Asians having small dicks other mom [ __ ]
speaks shitty English every asian guy
has a answer machine message from their
mother in their act every [ __ ] time
okay Middle Eastern comics just talked
about being uber drivers how hard is the
fly and how Super immigrant their dads
are everyone I know their dads is the
most immigrant [ __ ] you've ever
met in your life and that's a whole act
is about how [ __ ] it's like to be a
terrorist and they all want to be
Hillary Clinton fans and I get invalid
getting that later okay black comics
here black comics can rack on everyone
except gay people remember this is what
makes white women comfortable they can
record everybody they want they can do
the most racist [ __ ] on black people and
white women will laugh at it if they
talk about gay guys then why women
chicks will shut down on them you know
why women let this go making up for 300
years of oppression that's my patent
every black comic ah is every black
comic playlist of jokes joke list
includes women are crazy ah making fun
of a beyoncé song or a song that's
popular on the internet and [ __ ] on
white people that is your black comic
playlist of comedy go watch any black
comic those are the hits because that
makes white girls laugh I lost Aaron on
this it's bad guys pretty much I must
lost as to what this has to do with PC
culture because this is what why people
will
set Oh what they'll accept okay and what
they won't accept back on board back on
board okay I'm back so you don't get it
Hassan off at what their chai what black
comics are allowed to say they're
allowed to make fun of everybody but gay
guys yeah if they do gay jokes and [ __ ]
on gay guys the crowd will shut down on
them but they can rack everybody else
that white people white women Asians
other black like black comics can go off
on black people they can do jokes that
would make the Klu Klux Klan plush same
thing with Hispanics expand comics have
been lumped in with black comics which I
understand because they're two totally
different cultures but secretly white it
privileged guilty people lumped on the
same so all the same is for Hispanic
comics expand comics love talking about
racist their dads are oh how he's paying
people dance and smoking weed they can
wreak on everything just like gay guys
again white women won't take gate
Hispanic comics rack and white people
gay people okay a white guys can't make
fun of anything they can't make fun of
anybody but themselves their kids and
how they're lazy and their wife puts up
with their [ __ ] if they rack on women it
become sexism and they get shut down
they get shut down okay so white guys
can't make fun of anything because they
oppressed everybody forever and the fact
that most white guys remind white girls
other dads who didn't hug them enough in
high school and encourage them so
they're bad guys I feel like I lost they
aren't on this one female comics
listening female comics to make fun of
everyone like white guys can't do rape
jokes no matter what the rape joke is
they can't do a rape joke but white
female comics can make fun of everybody
and can do rape jokes and it's basically
your white female comic playlist is
basically uh this is what they talk
about are just all they want to talk
about how much [ __ ] they are and they
can't get boyfriends and there's a rape
joke in there are they all they talk
about is everything but they could talk
about anything
they want to but most of it is about
bitching about how sexist everyone is if
a female comic is a little bit funny she
moves to the front of the line she moves
to the front of the comedy line she gets
fast-tracked because there's not as many
of them so they get pushed to the front
of it mainly just right white guys dick
jokes and make them feminist jokes and
then everybody cheers about how [ __ ]
braid they are because what comes down
to and here's the big one gay esta
comics can rack everybody if RuPaul did
stand-up comedy he could [ __ ] call
blackmill the n-word call [ __ ] gay
guys a bunch of [ __ ] boys and call her
[ __ ] chicks [ __ ] and everybody
would laugh because it all comes down to
what will they let you say and I've just
bring their rules what that they won't
let me say anything then well let me say
anything I wasn't so Lisa Lampanelli and
she's less I want to saw her and Joe
Bartnik at the nokia theatre downtown in
LA I lift at the crowd it was all gay
guys and fat white chicks which are the
number one demographic for complaining
about political correctness and if you
hurt the [ __ ] that was coming out Lisa
lampanelli's mouth and they were going
[ __ ] crazy for and good for her
congratulations on that she deserves it
but you know if I went up in there
inside the [ __ ] they would shut down and
burn down the place which is the problem
political correctness there's too much
fine print yep there's too much fine
print you can't say one person can do
this that's not civil rights man and
that's why these white girls think they
can [ __ ] everybody nobody gives a [ __ ]
what you think it's just mediocrity now
you hear the new thing that Amy Schumer
is gonna be like ah Barbie what they
have a Amy Schumer playing Barbie I mean
comedic Lee that could be funny but
that's a great question is it going to
be a comedy oh of course it's got to be
interesting yeah you're right i guess i
could suck it up here there's not gonna
be a hard hard hitting bar p trauma but
what's the comedy about barbie
she finds out Ken's got no dick maybe I
don't I mean I don't know I didn't write
the day people are blowing going crazy
all over this Wow not yeah she's not
built like Barbie but nobody is nobody's
built like Barbie but it's like I don't
get it man I guess that must be the
thing i don't like it's a weird like
this is the we're stopping so catch i
see it working but as a filling my donor
yeah i mean like i'm gonna be honestly i
totally agree women when they say that
uh they get presented it and projected
horrible woman's Beauty images yeah and
it's all meant to [ __ ] their heads up
yeah that's all marketing's about and
but the reason I bring this up is
because there's this notion that women
just get forced to look at bad body
images of themselves it's unrealistic
but my question is who's doing that and
the notion is so he's guilty old white
guys who are petting cats met laughing
about making women feel bad and it's not
every meeting I've ever taken with a
marketer it's always gay guys and white
chicks who's doing it marketers are
doing it if you ever watched commercial
man it's always like you look at the mom
she looks about three years older than
her kids yep that's meant to [ __ ]
mentally [ __ ] women's heads yep yeah
but my point is who's making that to say
it's AG is that some old creepy guy not
known is rupert murdoch going make the
chick in the herpes commercial look like
she's [ __ ] 18 but she's supposed to
be 45 like is he doing that I don't
think so it's like it's a chick on chick
crime uh-huh and I wish they would say
that like this [ __ ] walk [ __ ] it's just
like who lose lose oppressing you you
love dick who's a person you for loving
dick not guys I never won't met one guy
ever complain about a chick being a [ __ ]
so joke I have men will go with new
super on [ __ ] we just call them they're
always welcomed call a joke it's it's a
got it it's an instant class ya got me
yeah it's an old classic too but it's
like there's this notion that people
like the black Santa thing have you seen
that there's a mall that a black Santa
supposedly people going I know one
person [ __ ] the only thing I hear is
people ask you
are you offended by Blackson no I'm not
I don't care he's fake he's not real
it's not a real thing black Jesus is
more realistic than black Santa cuz cuz
[ __ ] Jesus was a Middle Eastern yeah
he should be way darker Bell right hmm
but we got this [ __ ] blue-eyed
blonde-haired Jesus walking around like
looking like Sean Penn from [ __ ] fast
times at ridgemont high talking about
all he wants to some tasty puffs and
some choice waves ok stoner Jesus we
[ __ ] gotcha it's ridiculous dude like
i was listening this guy in the radio
last night talk about how everybody's
going off on Tom Brady trying to say is
that one degree who who doesn't think
Tom Brady is in the top two greatest
quarterbacks of Alta I've never heard
anyone argue that they argue like it's
tainted there's some [ __ ] that went on
yeah it's not just about the deflated
balls hombre it's about straight-up
videotaping peoples [ __ ] practices
that's what that's about stop acting
like that didn't happen it happened he's
still want the grace ever do it we're
fine with that nobody's saying he's not
stop backing like this it's like
nobody's [ __ ] about black Santa you're
just trying to cause problems and nobody
gives a [ __ ] nobody would even know
there was a black Santa sister Night
Live Comedy Central does it a lot I got
a project with comedy central I love
them i'm thankful that they're working
with me my projects still moving forward
but it's like you know that you did you
see this Trevor Noah vs ah Tommy leigh
leigh erin lee ryan Tommy Loran
something like that do you know this
chick is not a clue she's like she's on
this website called the blaze which is
hilarious sounds like I'm never gonna go
there yeah it's just a super-duper
concert' I love alcohol consumer we
should be called conservative we should
come up with another word for conserving
my mother's conservative she just sits
to herself like when you're angry with
rhetoric you're not conservative oh
you're aggressive right can we call it
aggressive it's this aggressive website
and this
girl goes on there and she just [ __ ]
him oh she's a 24 year old girl from
like North or South Dakota who just
loves the [ __ ] about the world and you
know and I say to you you've lived no
life to [ __ ] about the world what have
you done Tommy that with you gone to
have this knowledge of how the world
[ __ ] works what we've gotten here at
least Andy Rooney was old that there's a
reason why back in the day that mean
with the exception of Vin Scully for the
most part you were like well into your
40s if not 50s when you got that big gig
cuz you had to go around the world do
the [ __ ] gig to find out how the world
worked yeah like there's a reason for
that and it's not just like oh it's my
turn it's like no we need you to have
experienced so when you get here you
know what's going right what's going
wrong you know and this girl she's 24
dude for if she was a if she was a
comedian she'd still be an open like
she's still paid an open mic her man and
I everything she'd lip she's 24 she's
married to a Navy Seal and she's got
this job when she's getting like
millions people views and don't tell me
it's not the fact that she looks like a
talking eight ball of cocaine like she
looks like every chick in Tempe Arizona
will let you and your friends run a
train on her if you got an eight ball of
cocaine she's got these big teeth and
she's angry she looks like a honey
badger and she's just angry and she just
yells about [ __ ] she doesn't know so she
goes on Trevor Noah's ha showed the
daily show and they go at it and you
just read the clutter Trevor Noah
destroys Tommy Tommy Lee ran Loran Tommy
look man it's like he didn't destroy
anything because ultimately what he's
supposed to call her out on is something
you might actually be able to say about
him too it's like you're too young to be
doing this yeah you have no life
experience now Trevor Noah has a little
more life experience he's from South
Africa yeah but it's still it's he
didn't do enough he kind of got fast
tracked out there too he's a
good-looking light-skinned brother who
[ __ ] talk some [ __ ] South Africa went
through all this racial [ __ ] he kind of
stepped in and got shot to the front
yeah
you know did this he did not like this
chick up at all no he a great job ultimi
it's like tell me about your life Tommy
what have you done oh you're 24 and you
think you know how the world works
you're making you're making [ __ ]
comments an Occupy Wall Street when you
were like 16 when that was going down
and you're like well Sam you weren't
around during the Civil War how do you
know what that well because we know
about the basic thing is like oppressive
government rebels fight back we know
that's kind of how it worked out right
the Occupy Wall Street stuff she brought
up all the [ __ ] that wasn't even applied
to that about how they're like
idealistic and then they use military
tactics well what should what time he
doesn't know or doesn't bring up is that
[ __ ] police were busted dressing up
as [ __ ] protesters and rampaging
through places and they had a standoff
in which a SWAT team surrounded them
they surrendered and they got let go for
free they were doing it on purpose to
try to make the protesters look bad and
she doesn't know that she's commenting
on [ __ ] she's never seen man like she's
literally [ __ ] about [ __ ] she sees on
TV which is classic pop entertainment
which is something happened and you take
a hacky take on it cuz you have no real
life experience to decide on what's
going on she's just not good no she's
doing life no one twenty-four-year-old
it should never I'm EK sionally you get
a guy who's just like knocks out of park
you're like yeah that kids the one that
person's the one they're way beyond
their years but this woman shouldn't be
commenting on political [ __ ] when she's
lived no life you want to tell me how
the world works Tommy where have you
been what countries have you gone to an
argument what my friend during ah
leading up to Iraq Wars tell me how the
world works oh I'm like wavy bit he's
like well where it goes the Bahamas the
only place you bid is the Bahamas well
that's not [ __ ] life may have you
know people if you've tried the world
you notice about people everybody wants
to keep it simple they want to love they
want to laugh they want a beer they want
to get the dick wet or get laid and
that's it and take care of their family
everybody's on the basic
level and that's why I laugh when people
get old fights over this local person
Apple they don't give a [ __ ] about you
man they're playing a different game
they're playing war games with other war
game people and we're just [ __ ] ponds
and we'll get upset this girl Tommy has
no clue what she's [ __ ] talking about
she's making comments on the [ __ ]
like she's like oh I hate they occupy
wall street it will abuse military
actions so you're against the police in
North Dakota cuz that's all they've been
doing is making [ __ ] using military
tactics you know I used to be for real
gun control like let's use some [ __ ] but
after watching what happens when the
police show up and they show up in tanks
now we need to really think about what
kind of gun control we want cuz I don't
want to give up guns I just want to keep
away from crazy people I have no
solution to that but the notion just to
give up a gun I can't now with when they
show up in tanks now and hammers and now
they have like weaponized [ __ ] drones
which is the opening sequence to the
Terminator movie you see a terminator
walking over skulls with flying drones
looking to kill people yep it's crazy
it's stupid Tommy needs to suck it
that's all I needed her boyfriends like
a [ __ ] Navy SEAL good come kill me I
don't give a [ __ ] use a piece of [ __ ]
doll ah I'd be more interested in what
he has to say Trevor Noah no the Navy
SEAL he's lived yeah he's not some life
yeah you know these live some life but
there's also some brainwashing it goes
okay get to that level yeah did you got
by and I have no prob listen dude I have
no problem we're joining the military
because you want to offend your country
but I'm sure these guys ins put their
lives on the line to go to Afghanistan
and protect poppy fields because our
government wants to flood our country
with [ __ ] cheap heroin to get people
hooked on a bunch of [ __ ] so we you know
it's like it's a classic [ __ ]
iran-contra affair now we got this thing
you don't know about this pizza hut
thing right there's pizza gate I do not
I do not understand it okay Pizza gay
all right Pizza gay is basically this
arm
I'm all for thin crust I'm from Chicago
but I like in New York style I got what
you're saying I like what you're saying
yeah and that's not what pizza gate is
pizza gates basically this thing we're
this uh what is his name hold on real
quick Hamza for desk Podesta put the
desktop pedestrian who was behind all
the WikiLeaks email hmm there has been
some belief that there is some child
pornography child sex ring going on in
Washington DC now there's this is very
sensitive ah because people think this
is a woodshop well he was was a
Hillary's campaign manager yeah yeah
okay okay and I would be people flipping
out now supposedly happened at this
place called comet ping pong oh yeah
yeah that's where that guy was today
yeah yeah but well you know G okay for
all hold on child's I'm trying to look
up this guy's thing sex okay so
basically the thing is through these
through these Britt here it is this is
what I want to talk about through these
emails people have coded and started out
in a fortune which is the [ __ ] stain of
the Internet yeah there's some tin foil
hats there yeah okay so they put out and
they break down this code that there's
this [ __ ] going on based on this guy's
the the pizza places Instagram and the
guy who owns a personal Instagram
account now this guy who owns pizza get
a comet ping pong was doing the 49th
most powerful person in Washington DC
whether that's a joke or not I don't
know but he's a pizza guy in a town full
of powerful pizza powerful pizza people
& pizza there's some powerful pizza um
oh yeah this is the [ __ ] how is the
pizza I'm interested I don't know I'd
love to know how the pizza was too yeah
I would really love to know how the
pizza was to house the animatronic band
yeah good I would like to undo they rock
fine as [ __ ]
guys name this is okay here we go so put
Podesta and this guy Podesta and the guy
who owns comment best friends Podesta
and his brother hang out there all the
time Podesta his brother have weird art
in their house like really creepy ass
[ __ ] now there's a spear cooking going
on that involves children semen blood
that was found in the emails must weird
[ __ ] so without getting too far in it
because people's heads are exploding
okay people's heads are exploding with
this thing cuz there's some people are
really upset that this is a witch
hunting this doesn't mean anything but
my whole point is this I'm not saying
it's real I'm just saying look into it
look into it why I mean we've seen our
government do weirder [ __ ] and my
friends I go what the faking weapons of
mass destruction Iraq drone strikes
these false flags that go on all over
the world in orlando San Bernardino and
a lot of people don't know this man i'm
not going to talk about a lot because i
don't want to get in trouble dude but
it's like i watch that same bernardino
shooting happen in real time we're just
gotten done and the news crews and they
were interviewing people who were at the
shooting and saw it happened and they
all said four guys four white got all of
they interview for white guys in black
military fatigue walked through shooting
everybody and took off then i watch the
story change in real time i watch to
change to a milli CERN guy shot up a
christmas party i watch happen in real
time dude well yeah news is hard in real
time but but aaron there is that that is
a thing I mean the news does not know
[ __ ] until but the interview of the
[ __ ] eyewitnesses all said they all
saw four white guys shooting up the
place eyewitnesses are often unreliable
I'm not lying you're wrong we're going
for white guys in black two one dude
shooting up the place they saw the guy
these are my witnesses in San Bernardino
as well at the place monaghan oh the
meth capital of cal ok to say I mean
accessible it's a real okay reach so
anyways yeah I saw happen changing
real time you can you could totally say
that that that and that's what people
have said I've seen false flags I've
seen all this I've seen the possible
being behind the JFK assassination you
know if you think it's one bullet you're
a little crazy so there's all this
notions about how uh LBJ didn't want to
get out of Vietnam because he had stock
in the military industrial complex so
he's part of these guys who shot JFK to
keep us in to [ __ ] Vietnam there's
all this stuff if you believe all that
can happen if you book is one thing
someone else said to me is like they're
[ __ ] kids out of a pizza shop they're
[ __ ] kids out of subway subway guy
who is a face of subway was banging kids
said milk kids not literally you not the
init location right but are they saying
they're [ __ ] kids in in a beach shop
no that was where everybody [ __ ] Matt
yeah my point is it's like look how
they're recovering this case look at
what happens look at the Derrick Rose
case look at any pro athlete who gets
accused of rape they throw that story
out regardless of what the facts are
then they just throw it everywhere it
does if you're if you're a famous person
and there's some kind of [ __ ] sexual
misconduct you've been accused of
whether facts or it or not they run with
it yep they [ __ ] wrong way and they
rarely run the retraction and when they
do run a retraction it's page 16 yep so
was this thing you see no coverage of it
other than fake news fake news fake
story fake news fake news fake story so
now it comes out that this guy where is
this dude now it's coming out that this
dude who got caught shooting up a place
is an actual false flag actor his IMDb
is edgar medicine walsh let's look this
dude up let's look this dude up real
quick in real-time okay so you're saying
because he's an actor it's a false flag
well have you ever heard that um that
they use cuz actors aren't crazy trauma
actors foot well we'll see if they
actually say that's him okay yeah this
is him
yep maybe is maybe we're gonna find out
homeboy this is [ __ ] crazy easy a
real actor is he doing it out whoa this
is coming John Wilkes Booth was an actor
he really shot a guy famously that's
true that's true cuz act that's true a
little crazy that's totally true but you
know they're they're ours crisis actors
right have you heard about that thing
where they find picture of the same
chick at three different major crop they
show her boom boom boom no I'm we're
gonna have a false flag episode I can't
wait to you do this conspiracy theory I
can't wait okay but but everyone's like
oh come up with her [ __ ] ba ba ba ba so
in Britain there was a giant scandal
right of there's a giant scandal at the
highest level of British government with
this DJ called sir Jimmy savaii savala
SI VI le so he was in the government nej
he was he was knighted he was basically
like royalty he hung out with the
highest levels of British government and
when he died they went through all his
personal and they found out he was part
of a giant paedophile ring that involved
the Royals and the highest levels of
government hmm okay so my point being is
like why couldn't this be now area is
this I'm gonna sit down on the specifics
of a napkin or Hillary ran it am I
saying no specifics all right I'm just
I'm just saying look into look into it
yeah something [ __ ] could really be
going down or nothing and then just say
that I think whether smoke there's fire
yeah that's my opinion but speaking is
there's smoke there's [ __ ] fire so ah
that's my whole show I love you guys
comments I love everything next week
we'll have another episode and then
we're going to start doing the tin foil
hat podcast I want to play this out and
then we'll hit the road it's another
positive motivational thing I like to
leave you guys with I watch a lot of
these every day just kind of get my head
on my ass if you go to team fearless
youtube team fearless they got some
great videos and this is another video
for you guys and then we're going to go
out on this I love you guys very much
stick with me this is shows only gonna
get better next week we got Eddie Bravo
on the tin foil hat podcast here we go
together with Ari we gotta go through
this stupid ad here we go now enjoy
[Music]
amazing to all the cold nights what I
wanted to give up in at all I made I
made it to the store I made it to all
the Dallas I made it to the heinous they
look at me like I was trash so you must
be careful of what you look at you must
be careful in the things you see because
those things might be some of the
greatest things you have experience
because what you choose to see was safe
you will be
I know you had nights were you laying in
your bed and you didn't even have a
dollar I knew you had nice when you laid
in your bed and felt work but there was
no way you can make I know you had
nights we wanted to give up when you had
to pretend like everything was good but
on the inside you a guy that's the most
painful part of life we have human
beings that are dying inside because
they do not know the greatness
don't you let brightness lay down
anymore
let your greatness sleep it was realize
your potential you fight to one day
stand on a stage and say our main no
matter if you sent to highlight tape out
to different Scouts and they say can you
have what it takes no radio to their
musician and you send your musical and
they tell you it doesn't have
don't you let that be the last time
someone hears her gift because all it
takes is for what here their values what
you bring to the tape to give you a
virtue
you must be careful you hang around with
because a standard we said become the
resource we see the Santa's reset become
the life we leave you must realize your
work whatever happens you stay strong
you keep good
don't you let disappointment stop you
don't you I fail you stop you don't you
let your thoughts stop you development
play these are the steps you take to say
the works
I'm me
I made it I made it to the store to look
like it'll never sell make sure you
stick it out the one day you can say on
me
[Music]
cuz I stuck it
oh wow cuz I didn't listen to the nicer
to the doubt make sure you stick it out
for you
give it all
you
[Music]